hello everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be back
on with you guys again I have a very
special new guest introduced you to his
name is Gary Coxe
he what is he he is a speaker he is an
author he is a success coach he helps
people break through the liberty
personal beliefs and today we're going
to talk about staying condition for
success you may have seen him on the dr.
Phil show or on the dr. show he's
everywhere and anywhere mr. Gary Coxe
welcome aboard man what's up buddy good
to be here Evan she's awesome this is
exciting now looks like you're in a
hotel room where are you right now oh I
live in hotels man I'm in LA we just did
some filming last week and I've got some
presentations here some we're kind of
humming here in LA for a little while
while we're doing some of these TV shows
very cool so I'm actually making a video
coming up about YouTube channels to pay
attention to and included you on that
list of one of the up-and-coming
youtubers I know you're not
up-and-coming in your field but just in
the YouTube space it's it's a new
channel that I think people should check
out um yeah I want to talk about
limiting beliefs to kind of kick this
off because I know it's a big thing and
for people if you haven't heard about
Gary go check out his channel he's got
some great videos on there there's a
comedian who was afraid of snakes and
then he talks to Gary and now he's
wearing the snake on his neck and
there's a woman who wasn't charging
enough and had all these beliefs about
money from a rough childhood and like
Gary help kind of turn all that around
and I think I don't you know camp if I'm
wrong Gary but I think what holds a lot
of people back isn't the strategies of
the tactics but these limiting blocks
that we have in our mindsets and some
wondering how do people how do people
figure out what they are because we kind
of just live our life on autopilot and
these things are blocking us and we
don't I don't know until someone like
you comes along says hey Susie
you know you're failing yourself here
how do we figure out what those are
right well you know what's interesting
is when I when I went through a lot of
my challenges and not to bore you but I
mean I've been through a lot of stuff
everything from you know when I was
younger my wife
we have a baby she tells me it's not
mine my father's murdered my grandfather
and stepfather died at cancer my uncle's
killed in a plane crash all by the time
I was 21 years of age so you can only
imagine the emotional what I refer to as
my emotional hard drive when our
emotional hard drive is filled up we
have a hard time moving forward we'll
feel like we're pushing a parked car
we might be active but we're active
accomplishing nothing or we're taking
one step forward in 10 steps back so
when I had a lot of people do is when I
went through my challenge is that would
say you know you need to change the way
you think or you need to change your
story well my problem was okay I get
that but how how do you do it so most
people don't know how to change their
story you don't know how to change your
limited belief and for every belief we
act on we get a result so one of the
ways to know that we have a limited
belief is often by our results it's not
a hundred percent true because sometimes
we're just on the cusp of more success
but a lot of times we can look at the
results that we're getting in our
relationships or in our finances and
again for every belief we act on we get
a result so we're not happy with the
result we need to go in and identify the
belief system it's not just a belief
system to heaven because a lot of people
have you know we all have beliefs but
you can be a believer and have strong
belief but have no value or level of
importance on that belief and now we
were just a person who believes but
doesn't take action so okay so I'm not
getting results in my relationship or
I'm not not quite pushing through with
my business what questions do I ask to
kind of figure out what that block might
be well the questions like for example
in a relationships a lot of times when
we have an issue in a relationship the
problem methylate times is between me
and me not me and you so if you say
something to me and you're being kind to
me and it's nothing you know rude you're
just saying something very kind to me
and all of a sudden you know I trigger
something from the past
well now the problem really is between
me and me not me and you and if I don't
identify that then now I'm going to
start attacking you you're going to get
irritated you're going to come back and
mean that you have an explosion so we
need to identify in ourselves that the
biggest thing I tell people to do is
you've got to be really honest with
yourself you can't change what you don't
acknowledge so what is it about what you
said it's not
necessarily you but there's something
that you said that triggered an emotion
in me and if I can start taking more
responsibility internally then I can
start looking for the right reason or
where that came from or what stuck in my
emotional harddrive and for some people
where I come in they don't know what's
blocking them you know they know they
have the right attitude but something is
not right there they're moving forward
something happens and they stop for a
week or two and maybe they try again and
that's where I come and I go ahead and
help them identify some of that and then
change it quickly can we do it ourselves
and do we need that person to shine the
light and say look this is where you're
falling down uh you can do it both
alright because many times when we're in
the pit one when we're the picture in
the frame we have a hard time seeing the
blind spots
now there's other times that we can
learn to identify some of our blind
spots but that's not always easy because
again we're the picture in the frame but
yes we can identify our own beliefs our
own stories and sometimes they get so
deep or maybe we're so blind to it we
need somebody else to help us out but
absolutely we can do or said in fact I
constantly I'm always questioning where
I'm at on my thought process is that a
limited story that a thought process
that's going to slow me down
if I duplicated this thought that I'm
having right now what kind of result
would it get me that result is not in
harmony with my goals I need to change
the story or the belief hmm there are
there habits that you would recommend so
right there you're asking yourself daily
constantly you know is this a belief
that's limiting me or not other habit I
recommend people should do there's one
of the habits that I do every single day
of it I write down my goals every single
morning religiously if I wake up at 4
o'clock in the morning to fly out I'm
going to write my goals before I jump in
that airplane but yeah that's one of the
things I do and the reasons I do this
for is because number one it keeps me
extremely focused and if I'm extremely
focused then I know where I need to be
in what I need to do today also because
I have really huge ridiculous goals
written down there's some days when I
write them down it's like man I can make
this happen this is a no-brainer then
there's other days or somebody you know
got me knocked off my feet or
I write down that goal like I did
yesterday I do it today and I go holy
moly how in the world am I ever gonna
even attain that so it's a great
measuring Rhonda to help us analyze to
where we are I love it so people are
responding to that in the live chat like
every single day you do this every day I
make an exception um I usually don't do
it on Sunday Sunday is my chill day but
I read it Sunday because I want to keep
my momentum but yeah so what I do today
I wrote these all down so tomorrow I'll
take this off tomorrow morning I'll take
this off and I'll rewrite the goals all
over again
it takes me five minutes if I can't
devote five minutes to my success every
day then I'm just - it is hmm and then
do you use that as feedback so if you're
not hitting your goal is that when you
start the question hey what's the reason
behind this absolutely I'll look at
something like this and go wait a minute
you know I've been on this goal for X
amount of time what's the deal here I'm
either too distracted um maybe talk is
cheap maybe my value isn't you know high
enough and I need to change that so yeah
it's one of the best ways to analyze
where you need to be on your level of
success and your journey it's huge hmm
so we've got an entrepreneur audience
people who are in business or want to
start a business uh what do you find as
being the biggest blocks that
entrepreneurs face on their path that
holds them back I'd say the biggest
block is they don't look at things
they're big enough um you know you hear
everybody say you got to think big and
dream big but there's a problem with
that you need to think big but you need
to believe in the big so the challenge
here is when we think about you know
dreaming bigger and going big is if we
can't believe it we got a problem
so the problem here is many times let's
say what we know we're all here wherever
here is Evan and we want to go here
well the the distance between hair and
hair is usually so huge that we allow
ourselves to have so much negativity
stumbling-blocks
limited beliefs whatever it is between
here and here so what I get people to do
I get them to learn how to do things
daily but get them excited to this level
here for example I'm
massively passionate about aviation I
love aviation I fly jets and helicopters
and I'm an instructor and twin engines
in the whole nine yards
well when I first started if I had a
goal to fly a jet you just don't you
know get down here and say I'm gonna
have a jet fly a jet and just be right
up here so you can do little things you
could go to an airport and stand in
front of a jet and take a picture that
doesn't cost much but that gets you
excited you could maybe rent a jet you
could get five friends at five thousand
dollars or a thousand dollars apiece get
in a jet fly half an hour it doesn't
matter get it in your system and this is
where I get people to understand that
you can learn to live the lifestyle of a
millionaire now do the little things now
for example something simple for
entrepreneurs to keep themselves geared
and and excited if you can't afford to
have your house clean why don't you have
your house clean I don't care if it's
once every three months just the fact
that you do it this is what successful
people do I have a very good friend of
mine who's my billionaire mentor and I
watch his lifestyle and the thing is
with entrepreneurs we have a tendency of
wearing too many hats that's just that's
just the way it is when you start off
you start off with a lot more time than
you do with money right so what happens
is we end up having to do everything the
goal for an entrepreneur is the moment
they get the cash flow and they need to
work toward the cash flow their next
goal is to take a hat off and give that
hat to somebody else hire somebody and
then of course when we think about
hiring somebody we think wow we got to
hire somebody for for 40 hours we know
you know about outsourcing so when we do
little things like that and do it now
it's amazing what we're capable of doing
and how excited we get about our future
success so what I hear tell me if I'm
capturing it right you think
entrepreneurs can think big but they
don't necessarily believe in the big
thing yet and taking little steps even
if they can't necessarily they can't
afford to have somebody full-time or
cleaning the house just have a little
taste of it because that helps improve
the belief that you deserve and can have
it that's the key and then when you
taste it it tastes so good so what do
you do
Wow I want more of this so how do you
get more but you got to raise your game
you know yeah it's a bad analogy
gee but it's like somebody you know I've
never done drugs but it's like somebody
who does drugs you know you give them a
shot or whatever goes oh my gosh this
feels good so what's their next thing
after the high goes down their next
questions I got to get more how do I get
more you do some really stupid things
you know you break into people's houses
whatever so the point is if you're not
giving yourself a fix
you're too prone to discouragement give
yourself a fix and then that looks you
excited to get more and do more and do
more interesting I like it
we're getting some questions here necie
Jordan is asking what else is in your
daily regimen what else is in my daily
regimen with regards to my success well
I think people really interested in the
gold thing that you get every day so
like what else I would get up what else
do you do yeah well I have a sales team
and I have a team of people I have about
10 people that support me so one of the
things that I do is I need I need to
know my numbers all of the time I want
to know what my numbers are and numbers
don't lie so if you're even just a lone
star by yourself and in part of your
career your entrepreneurship involves
making phone calls you need to know how
many calls you're making I don't care if
it's ten you need to write it down and
the other thing is that I recognize in
my routine I always know one thing about
success it will always Evan take you
more money time effort and energy so I
need to make sure that my energy is set
where I can do more so part of my
routine is I've got a diet like you know
because we get a hotel with an
efficiency I have an assistant travel
with me so we have a hotel we have a
fridge and everything so my morning
starts off with a frozen milkshake it's
not me it's not a good milk I don't even
drink milk it's a frozen shake I've got
frozen tumeric frozen ginger frozen
avocado I've got a wheat plant that lead
grass in there plant-based protein and
then I mix that up every morning that's
how I start my morning so my morning is
very very strict and very very
regimented to get out of the gate very
quickly and I do you know I'll do like a
hundred hours a week and think nothing
up that's my regular routine for me I'm
a nut I love it
Valentin is asking if I first we see
good results but then we get stuck
how do we get out of this stuck zone the
only way I know how to get you out of
the stucked zone is what's the store
that's causing to be stuck and that's
probably one of the stories right there
you're telling yourself you're stuck so
when you weren't stuck what was the
behaviors that you had to show that you
weren't stuck and then you need to mimic
those behaviors again because you being
stuck has been associated by this by
something that happened to you
where you're staying oh crap I'm stuck
you know it's like writer's block I
don't believe there's such a thing as
writer's block I don't get stuck in
writer's block if I block myself two
hours to write it from two o'clock to
four o'clock when two o'clock comes I'm
just going to start writing so basically
figure out what it is that happened that
you got stuck in your emotional hard
drive about your business yesterday five
days ago whatever it is that made you
feel stuck and that's a story that's
causing you to stop and put you in the
tracks where you right now and you've
got to change that to move forward mmm
most people when they're here they'll
say well I'm stuck because the economy
is not great or my customers aren't
buying now Lord's Christmas season or
like there's always something external
right there Ned Ned all crap all crap
absolutely you know when I when I hear
stuff like that it's like like I tell
people there's there's some principles
to financial success one of them you
have to save money then you have to
invest it so I ask people you know
saving money because over 70% of people
don't save money they work from paycheck
to paycheck so is it a money problem or
a mindset problem well you and I know
it's a mindset problem but a person who
doesn't save and live from paycheck to
paycheck
they will validate to themselves every
week that it's a money problem because
they don't have any money left over at
the end of the week well haven't you
seen professional players that you know
athletes they get five million dollars
and they spend five million dollars on a
penny so they're out of money - is it a
money problem or am i problem it's a
mindset problem so yeah there's no such
thing as there's not enough money out
there or the economy you know you might
have to work a little harder or you know
look at your strategies and maybe work a
little smarter but it's that type of
thinking that messes people up three
things I hate people that live people
that are not on time and people who make
excuses don't friggin make excuses man
you can't change what you don't
knowledge if you make excuses you can't
acknowledge it you're screwed is there a
favorite question you like to ask people
did you taking through this process
um yeah when I work I have a four step
process like like like for example um I
just did a recent case while I can't
discuss the case because it's not not
going to be aired yet so when I take a
case and I work with somebody I have
enforce that process Evon that I
developed that I show people how to
change their behavior the first thing I
ask them and everybody here is this but
I got a twist on this really changes
people thinking is why why do you want
to change this behavior
now everybody out there you hear you
know you'll have all heard it you have
to have your why so my question to that
is who doesn't have a why everybody has
a lot so if you have a why and everybody
has a why and we're told you got to have
your why that's why people fail because
they don't have a why everybody has a
why so what's the real reason the reason
is you don't have a high enough value on
your Y your Y will always be there but
if you get hit in the gut your value
your level of importance of that Y will
decrease you still have a wide but it's
not very high right now you get a great
sale what happens now your Y it's still
there but now it increases the higher
you can keep that increase in value on
that Y and you have a belief with it
that's what causes you to take action so
I first find out from somebody what's
your reason to change this behavior
what's your reason to keep going and
then I tell them I want you to know that
what you wrote down to me is going in
one Erin out the other because I don't
know yet if it's very important to you
just because you say it is doesn't mean
it is you can take a thousand people who
want to quit smoking cigarettes right
and you ask them how many of you in here
want to change and quit smoking just
about everybody's going to put their
hand up why is it that only a small few
will change even though they all have a
reason why the few the change have a
higher level of importance on why they
need to change I loved it there was a
lot that was said just there and I
encouraged people to play that section
back on the replay a couple of times to
let it actually sink in I loved it
um people asking who is your mentor so
where have you learned this stuff from
who are you who are your mentors right
now well
I don't have any actual I have a
billionaire mentor from the business
standpoint a lot of this stuff that I
learned from Bing come becoming my own
doctor at my own patient Evan when I
went through all these tragedies you
know before all these tragedies you know
I was doing well I was making $100,000 a
year as a teenager I mean that was crazy
and then after I had all these tragedies
of the wife telling me the baby's not
mine and all this nonsense
I lost everything and I learned one
thing that the difference was my
experiences I had a lot of negative
experiences that I created negative
associations that I created negative
behaviors so I became my own doctor in
my own patient I tried to figure out why
am i behaving the way I'm behaving and I
could relate to so much of it from the
crap I had been through and then as I
became my own doctor my patient if you
will then I started to learn strategies
on how to make change faster and faster
and faster
I just became obsessed with showing
people how to change their behavior on
the business side I'm very blessed that
I have a billionaire mentor I watch him
and study him I learned a lot from him
and that's that's my mentor to this day
your honor so I you but you identify
something that you know is a pattern
that I need to break a way of thinking
my story is broken you challenge me on
my why to say like is that actually
important to you or not and then I you
know I tell you that it is you know so
what what's my next action step how do
I'd now break through this the next
action step that this is kind of cool to
JSA I actually do a process when people
hire me for speaking I actually do a
process my four step process on stage
will then bring somebody from the
audience who has a huge psychological
limitation and I literally reprogram
them onstage without any hypnosis right
so the next thing I figure out from the
person is what's your limited beliefs if
let's just use this something tangent
let's say you're afraid of a snake and I
do a lot of stuff with you know tangible
phobias to describe or show the audience
how quick change can debate so if I were
to say to you let's say let's pretend
Evan that you are really phobic of a
snake I would want to find out what's
the limited belief in your head that
causes you to be phobic of a state so if
I say to you why are you
of the snake Evan and I would say to you
I don't care how stupid it sounds just
tell me what comes to your mind and
you're gonna say it's gonna swallow me
it'll attack me it's slimy
so now if I believe that and I responded
to that same belief I would be afraid of
snakes too so the next thing is that
identify what's in your head that's
limiting that's slowing you down forever
Limited belief you act on you get a
result then the next thing that we have
to do now is we have to change it to an
empowering belief you have to go from a
limited belief to an empowering belief
so if I said to you the snake is okay
it's not going to swallow you
that's the empowering belief the snake
is not going to swallow me but to you
it's not empowering yet because you
don't believe it so my big point I like
to share with people is how do you know
that you bought a belief most people
don't know that you need to know how you
know you bought a belief and the reason
that's important because for every
belief you act on you get a result and
if you don't if you bought a belief then
you're kind of screwed how you know you
bought a belief is when you say it and
you feel it that's your measuring rod
this is why positive affirmations really
screw people up see before you can go to
an empowering belief you first start off
with your limited belief in between is
the affirmation now the more you say a
positive affirmation the less you
believe it that's why you keep saying it
let me repeat that the more you keep
saying a positive affirmation the less
you believe it that's why you keep
saying when I woke up this morning and
shaved I didn't look at myself in the
mirror and say you're a man you're a man
you're a man I got it
right so what I have to learn to do
though is I have to learn to take that
affirmation and convert it to a belief
so let's go back to our limited beliefs
if you're limited belief is the snake is
going to swallow you when I ask on a
scale of 1 to 10 how much of that do you
believe you would write down the number
10 how do you know that because you say
it and you feel it so now it becomes a
belief so the Empowered believe is is
it's not going to swallow me well how do
we know you don't believe that because
when you say it's not going to swallow
me do you feel it's not going to swallow
you know I feel it's going to swallow me
so we know we have a measuring rod to
let you know if you believe it or not
when we get you to say the empowering
belief and you say it and feel it boom
that's when you bought a believe and
that's immediately wind change will be
made interesting in fact I just I'll
have to let you guys know I just did a
shot um with dr. feel like I got to be
very vague about it because it hasn't
been released this is a lady who was
attacked she was so attacked that
whatever it was that attacked her and I
got to keep that big she could hear her
bones crush she was put in a coma for
months right
she was so bad the worst case I've ever
had happen that when I started my
session with her within 60 minutes
I'm sorry within 60 seconds she was
almost in like a state of convulsion
right she was just shaking like I've
never seen anything like before in one
session we totally had her reversed
without him to hypnosis and all we did
was that with her on that was to check
get her to change her association you
can't change what happened to you in the
past but you can change the way you look
at it and if we learn to look at things
differently on a consistent basis then
we can really accelerate our success so
let me ask you this to make it a little
more personal I don't like roller
coasters okay I don't like not being in
control of my body and so I fight it you
know I could give that a real question
doing no I don't want to put my hands up
in the air I want to fight that thing
and as a result of integrally kosis so
my reaction has been okay I'm not gonna
go on rollercoasters and it's fine this
is that something that maybe holds me
back in other areas that I'm not aware
of is that something that then you dive
into and try to figure out you know
respectfully I'll tell you yes and I'm
going to give you a different look at it
and maybe a light will go on yeah
for me when I would be if I were to be
in your situation the way I look at it
is I am allowing external stimuli like a
roller coaster and a piece of metal and
experience to control my emotions mm-hmm
so what I don't want and I don't like I
don't like other things controlling my
mind and emotions now as a pilot when I
go onto on a commercial airliner I let
go I don't want to be controlled by oh
my gosh is he going to be safe what am I
going to do I don't like that I like to
have emotional freedom and when we allow
things like that to
control or emotions we lose that
emotional freedom when you have that
emotional freedom you also control your
stress factor so what that tells me
possibly when you're having a really
really bad day you probably react in
simpler ways not in the exact way of
sitting in a roller coaster but if you
are more consciously aware of how to
control that you'll be able to control
your stress factor to a whole different
level than the average person so yeah it
has a lot to do with it in fact that's
one of the whys I get people add more
value in why do you want to change this
behavior one of the reasons for us to
change our behavior should be to have
more control of our mind and emotions
and when you learn to control your mind
and emotions that to me evan is the
umbrella of learning how to master
everything else underneath that very
cool why I have some thinking to do on
general is little toasters to go check
down oh man thank America because it's
so funny you said that I was I was just
about but I don't know maybe a month and
a half ago I went on some rollercoasters
and there's this one it's not like a
roller coaster it's a long huge thing of
like 30 people they strap you in and it
spins around like crazy man so I wanted
to apply what I just shared with you I
wanted to have so much control that I
could actually hold my phone and video
it and you can see me just turning
around but I had to have enough control
where I wouldn't freak out and let go my
friggin phone that you know these stupid
smart phones cost but there's so many
different areas in life that you can use
that for to have more control very
important because see when we lose
control emotionally we disengage so what
happens for entrepreneurs we you know we
all know being an entrepreneur it could
be a roller coaster but if we lose some
of that emotional role that emotional
control
we are constantly engaging and
disengaging and engaging and disengaging
and that costs us emotionally so if we
can learn to keep that emotional
roller-coaster a lot smaller we have the
ability to take action and do more steps
and work toward our success a lot faster
than a person who's less like this all
the time especially in in business and
being an entrepreneur very cool well I'm
going to sleep on that I have some
digging to do there I appreciate that I
you want something check this one out
and I'm not doing this to plug in
anything I've got
look evidence called and I don't like
seeing the pluck it or anything so much
but it's kind of show you could with an
item for sure what is it we want in here
it's how to make your thoughts disappear
all right look at that
let me show you something let me show
you something that's powerful you have a
bigger felt pen my black felt pen may be
out perfect thank you sir all right
can I go but can I give you a couple
minutes on this yeah yeah
all right so think of the words here
when probably most of us heard this one
before
thoughts I think you can see that T R T
de AR have enough thoughts create
emotions emotions create actions actions
great results so if we have a negative
thought we create a negative emotion now
imagine if we can make our thoughts
disappear we don't have a negative
emotion we don't have a negative action
so we won't have a negative result so
that's one of the things that I teach
people to do our thoughts are so
powerful man think about it as
somebody's phobic of that roller coaster
or a situation just the thought of it
can make their heartbeat increase can
make their palms sweat imagine if we can
tap into the power of being able to do
the opposite of that how much control we
can have so the other thing I show
people how to do is what if you have a
negative thought
the area of success and expertise and
focus needs to be right here because we
all have negative thoughts from time to
time that's just part of being human but
if we could learn to take that negative
thought and change it where we now go
ahead and create a different emotion not
a negative one then we get a different
action then we get a different result
and this is kind of a way of
illustrating how powerful our thoughts
are very cool and that's in the book how
to make your thoughts in here that's in
this book yeah that's in this book it's
on my website they get on my website
cool check it out well Gary man it's
crazy how quickly happens an hour goes I
know you do go chin and take people you
know you fly them to islands from
Florida and you do intensive programs
you've got your book your YouTube
channel your website what's the best
place for people to kind of learn about
you connect take it to the next level
they like what they hear they want to
learn more I appreciate that Evan they
can go to my website
Gary Coxe calm you just don't forget the
EEG a hour
i co XE calm if you want to join with me
with me on the Bahamas for my mastermind
event you go to that website or go to
beyond first class with Gary calm beyond
first class with Gary calm there's a
some information there they can fill out
and before you know it I'll be picking
you up in the airplane we'll be going on
an exotic island for five days and just
disengaging from the regular world good
stuff
allowable Gary thank you so much for
spending time with us good luck in all
your travels around the world changing
lives continue to believe everybody and
we'll see you soon likewise thank you
Evan